I don't think there isn't like an
interest for like running for office
among women I think it's more of a
systemic problem it's more of a cultural
problem where you know women aren't
always told through society that you
know we are capable of having these
positions especially when you're looking
at Congress and it's eighty percent male
and you know right now that's actually a
pretty diverse group when you look
historically but when you don't see
women in these positions it's very hard
to imagine yourself acquiring this
position and so as we see more women
fill these positions with Hillary
Clinton may be running for president I
really hopeful that in the future you
know women will realize that we can do
this and we can do it better even better
than men so you know I don't think there
is this lack of interest or anything
like that I think it's just you know the
ability to look up and see people that
you want to be like
so we have two new programs the politics
of race and ethnicity and the campaign
and advocacy program and so the politics
of race ethnicity is a program that's
two pronged one it's to increase
dialogue among students on issues that
they care about with a nuance of race
and ethnicity so each week they have a
discussion on a different topic and they
talk about how ethnicity and race play a
part in that topic so that can range
from a cigar serration to education to
health care etc and then they also work
with the other 14 programs at the iop to
make sure that we're having these
discussions in all areas of the
institute which i think is you know even
the mo the more important mission of
politics of race ethnicity program and
then the campaigns and advocacy program
is also really interesting because it
gives students the tangible skills to go
out in the real world and make change on
issues they care about through electoral
politics which is you know right now I
think a where young people are a little
disillusioned when you when you look at
electoral politics and all the money and
in the rhetoric it's you know sometimes
it's a little hard to see where you can
make a change in that arena on then I
think cap does a really good job of
showing you different paths that you can
take right out of college as a young
person can make a difference and that's
what we want to do we want to be
effective we want to make a difference
it's inspiring you know I'm coming to
the Institute of Politics every day and
talking with my peers you can tell
people want to make a change they don't
want the future of politics to look like
it does now they wanted to be more
effective they want to help people they
want to help their communities and there
are so many opportunities at the iop to
give people the skills to do that and
that's what people are interested in
they don't want to you know see the
partisanship continue they want to work
together I come to the iop and I have
friends who are Democrats and
Republicans and independents and you
know and we all talk with each other and
we all talk about you know what we think
would be you know proper solutions to
helping you know us move forward and not
just stop ourselves so I'm really
excited for it i think it's going to
look a lot different i think it's going
to be a lot more diverse and i think
that's that's always a good thing